ouais c'est le fameux croche-patte l'a
donc pas très original alors violences
policières tout à fait dérisoire par
rapport aux florilèges que nous offre la
police depuis deux trois quatre ans est
d'ailleurs assez intéressant que quand
il était interviewé sur chaîne du
service public récemment
edouard philippe c'est cette image de
violences politiques ont bien montré et
pas les autres
oui mais parce que je pense qu'elle
paradoxalement alors qu'elle est
vraiment dérisoire encore une fois par
an elle dit beaucoup de chose de dur du
reste et notamment elle dit la charge
affective qui a dans la violence
policière c'est à dire que la police a
le monopole de la violence légitime
comme on dit et qu'est ce que ça veut
dire le mot n'est pas l'avion c'est
légitime quand la loi est elle même pas
légitime
bon ça c'est les gens pour interroger
cette expression mais la police est
fondamentalement violente légitimement
ou pas bon là il ya un élément de
gratuité c'est à propos de toutes
violences policières un flic ou un
ministère de l'intérieur pourra toujours
dire qu'il ya une utilité à la violence
policière dispersé émane des
manifestants parfois les taper un peu
brutalement pour les dissuader le côté
dissuasif de la force bon ça peut
toujours se ramener à une utilité
ça a pas du tout c'est le geste de trop
c'est le geste surnuméraires c'est le
sait le zèle policier un peu ludique
d'ailleurs le crush pas de ces cours de
récré un peu et là on voit quand même
que les policiers pour être les
dépositaires de l'ordre neutre
républicains pour autant dans sont pas
des gens neutres
c'est dire que quand même ce qu'on dit
pas assez par delà les effets de
structure de la police c'est que les
policiers sont des individus et qui sont
constitués idéologiquement or on sait
très bien que notre police française
notamment je sais pas si c'est le cas
exactement dans d'autres police ce
serait intéressant de l'étudier on sait
que un nombre significatif de free combo
ont voté extrême droite un aux dernières
élections ont voté le rassemblement
national
on en est sûr vraiment à il ya beaucoup
de sondages qui vont dans ceux d'études
un d'études non pas de son âge qui vont
dans ce sens là
bon de toute façon je pense qu'une
constitution majoritairement droitière
des flics français je verrai je le dis
sans sans même les incriminer c'est un
état de fait
alors c'est quand même intéressant de
voir que bombe à ceux qui sont des
gardiens de l'ordre républicain ne sont
pas neutres comme la république devrait
l'être ils sont tout à fait orienté de
logiquement donc ils aiment bien
qu'assez du gauchiste il ya un plaisir
de casser du gauchiste
[Musique]